for you uh when it comes to like the pen
game like how active are you still for
writing other artists like writing for
other artists rather right now I just
been in my own world so like I just been
complete my solo projects completing
this race room project you know saying
just keep them up keep them active just
stay writing stuff like I just write
and you never know where it's gonna go
like I might write a song five years it
might go to another artist you know I'm
saying it might go to me I might drop it
myself like I just let
like features and stuff they just happen
organically with me like I might run
into an artist you know saying we sit
down we play some we see where the Vibes
go but do you like do the punching thing
or do you lay the melody first and then
go back and do the lyrics like what's
your process if I'm really just locked
in I already got some ideas on my head I
can just freestyle like swing that was a
freestyle lit like big that was a
freestyle yeah like Unforgettable yeah I
wrote that like two bars at a time like
three bars at a time just float and just
piece it together and just like you know
saying just I just went with like a
climax and just like
emotional roller coaster on that
[__] like just up and down on
that one you want some weed Jimmy
these are the pre-rolls these are like
the guys Jordan these are all right
if you made them I'll smoke them but I
don't know
[__] you bro I'm saying the mid this
ain't the shake I need to roll one up
man what's that [__] bro I need to roll
on a set the first artist ever to roll
one on this on the show like the 38th oh
damn
I want to do some shrooms we could do
that uh they ain't gonna kick in during
the interview I already took shots at
the last one
they ain't gonna kick in during the
interview we're gonna be somewhere else
geeking geeked out
um
what about you Jimmy what's your writing
process like man like when you get in
the booth are you are you writing [__]
down are you punching in what's your
process you know I just want to like I
don't really want to speak on that right
now I want to wait till the album drop
because I feel like this album is gonna
be a
like like I said all our albums you can
see the growth in this and this one's
gonna be super
big growth you dig what I'm saying
because how do you feel like you grew
like the most from from this time that I
took off I grew in every single way like
but you know I'm gonna let my action
show that's why I'm at in my life right
now I feel like I'm in the show improve
era you did what I'm saying and that's
what I'm doing and I'm going crazy and
I'm gonna keep doing that is there a
tour in the works boys yeah it's a tour
in the works are you guys headlining you
guys getting on someone else's tour
what's going on we're going on tour with
post Malone uh but yeah we're doing
Coachella after we come back we're doing
our own headline tour after that yeah
should we go on our tour with post
Malone yeah we're going toward post uh
Europe tour of London yes
um like would make sense Germany to go
yeah
yeah it makes too much sense that's twin
man Shout Out Post Malone because he's
on your guys's album
it only makes sense that you guys go on
tour with them because he's one of the
two features on the contests their own
tests yeah
[Laughter]
they got us man
am I right
start the countdown man you know what I
love is that you haven't said no start
the countdown man like if I said Ozzy
Osbourne's on the album you'd be like
nah that's crazy no